[Applause]
is
how you doing freedom lovers i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it's april 15th in the year of
2022 the video that you just saw that
cold open we just showed you that was
elon musk you've heard of this guy uh he
was at the big opening event for tesla
in austin texas as you know he took him
out of cali about a year or two ago
amidst the lunacy of covid craziness in
california and the taxes and the big
government and the regulation and all
that stuff he moved him to free texas
and they had this bananas event if you
haven't seen the video don't stop
watching this okay obviously not but
there is video that you can find on the
computer machine where they had drones
and a really just awesome show and i
wanted to show you that because
obviously we're going to talk a bit
about elon musk today uh most
importantly though today
ladies and gentlemen is day two
of the post woke world this is a phrase
that i have coined and i believe
it is what is happening right now the
fight is on
it's not just about complaining and
exposing anymore
that sounded kind of funny uh it's not
just about that though it's about
actually how do we defeat the woke and
build new things that's exactly what
elon musk is all about and that's what's
happening in this twitter situation
right now that's what i've been trying
to do for quite some time and many
others and the signal has been sent
around the universe throughout the
galaxy it is time to fight speaking of
fighting people although facebook would
not let us put ads up about it and
twitter would not let us put ads up
about it i am going on tour that's right
it starts this tuesday in west palm
beach with donald trump jr and then i'm
off to clearwater florida with benny
johnson of turning point raleigh north
carolina with andrew clavin of the daily
wire atlanta georgia with the willy
wonka of politics michael malus chicago
illinois with the wonderful majestic
freedom-loving yonmi park dallas texas
with glenn beck of the blaze washington
d.c with former view host i'm going to
have to ask her about that uh megan
mccain west nyack new york with the
lovely and extraordinary megan kelly
brea california with the one and only
dennis prager uh oxnard california with
my man the black face of white supremacy
larry elder san jose california with
british conservative douglas murray
phoenix arizona with both the future
senator of arizona blake masters and
turning point usa's own charlie kirk and
then finally denver colorado with
comedian extraordinaire brian callan you
can get your tickets right now at
daverubin.com
events and again vip tickets you get the
one second hug every single ticket vip
or not comes with a book okay there you
go all right so let's recap what's going
on with this elon musk twitter story
this is the story and again even if
you're not on twitter and god bless you
for not being on there and keep doing
what you're doing with your life it's a
huge story because twitter is right in
the center of the battle for free speech
it is the public square where whether
you like it or not the old days of the
guy going to the town square and ringing
a bell and demanding people listen to
them or long gone it is just the center
of how we communicate with each other
these days even if it's just a small
section
of americans from an american
perspective who are on there it's where
all the politicians are it's where all
the taste makers are it's where all the
culturally relevant people are and so
much of that leaks down into all of our
lives so it is what it is so elon musk
as you know he has now offered to buy
twitter at a crazy price about 44
billion dollars real quick i'll show you
the letter that he sent to brett taylor
who's the chairman of the board i read
this yesterday so i'll do it real quick
i invested in twitter as i believe in
its potential to be the platform for
free speech around the globe and i
believe free speech is a societal
imperative for a functioning democracy
however since making my investment i now
realize the company will neither thrive
nor serve this societal imperative in
its current form twitter needs to be
transformed as a private company as a
result i'm offering to buy a hundred
percent of twitter for 50. four dollars
and 20 cents per share a 54 premium over
the day before i began investing in
twitter and a 38 premium over the day
before my investment was publicly
announced my offer is my best and final
offer and if not accepted i would need
to reconsider my position as shareholder
elon musk okay so what's the guy doing
he wants to bring free speech back i am
not going to sit here and pretend that
he is a god or a perfect man or any of
those things but he's pretty damn good
and he can do whatever he wants in this
world and he's chosen to get in the
fight put his money where his mouth is
get into a fight that is so murky and
messy and gross and evil and the way the
mob comes for you and to fight the woke
machine it's like he could do anything
and he chose to do this so this is
pretty awesome it's whether whether he
gets it or not it's awesome because it's
a signal that we can fight and you know
how i feel about the signal uh barstool
sports uh ceo dave portnoy who you guys
probably know he had an interesting
twitter thread on what's going on here
that i wanted to show you he said so
elon offered 41 billion to buy all of
twitter now the board decides if they
want to sell it to him it's a no-brainer
offer and they'd all make a [ __ ] ton the
only reason to say no is because they
don't like him right do i have that
right and if they say yes then everybody
who owns any twitter stock basically
gets cashed out at 54.20 a share and it
all goes to elon that's wild so maybe
it's not that great an offer maybe the
twitter board thinks they are smarter
than elon and can get it to 75 a share
but if they don't sell
the stock price is going to crash i
think elon has them by the balls so
without getting into too much of the
nitty-gritty related to stocks and how a
guy like elon musk just saying he's
interested in something much less
purchasing a part of it much less making
an offer for the full freaking thing how
that can change the value of the stock
which is exactly what portnoy is
referencing there and of course it's
exactly what elon himself is referencing
in the letter um
the game is afoot okay there is
something seriously interesting now try
to imagine you're you're a board member
of twitter you're one of the people who
has to make the decisions around this
you're not just the ceo but you're a
board member you're an influential
shareholder
you are going to make a crazy amount of
money on this why would you be saying no
most of these people invest in these
things to make money now of course some
people invest in things purely for
ideological reasons and if you were a
free speech warrior 10 years ago who
invested in twitter
are you happy with the way twitter is
working out on the free speech front i
mean maybe it's censored a lot of the
people you wanted censored maybe it
killed the biden laptop story and that
got the president you wanted but are you
really happy with how this thing has
turned out is there any chance that
someone is going to come in and give a
better offer like this is what every
company every startup every every tech
venture this is what they want like the
billionaire to come in and buy the
freaking thing and take the headache off
their hands these people all have
massive headaches
so we shall see what they do it seems
like a no-brainer i can't imagine
they're going to get a higher offer
the issue that i think might be going on
and i don't think you're going to hear
that much about this in mainstream media
is i suspect that under the hood of
twitter there is so much dirt i mean
deep dirt relative to how the hunter
biden story got killed how they made the
decision to get rid of donald trump how
they've decided to at times suspend
people like me for saying that vaccine
mandates were coming back in july when
they obviously were coming and then i
was suspended how they've gotten rid of
tons and tons of accounts always right
leaning or conservative leaning whatever
you want to call it how they've done all
of this stuff if that is all exposed if
emails are exposed and especially look
it doesn't matter you know whether they
suspend a guy like me or something like
that in terms of legal ramifications but
if there are real emails related to
connections with governments and how the
trump thing went down and the hunter
bundle up there is a huge amount of
problems here and i think maybe they
realize that maybe elon realized he
opened a parendora's box and now he has
to go for the full thing i i don't know
obviously but i think there's a lot here
i think it would be pretty damn awesome
maybe elon will buy the whole thing and
then appoint trump the ceo wouldn't that
be something bring trump back on trump's
the ceo and then every day trump does a
reality show where he just fires another
lefty from twitter hillary you're fired
wouldn't that jennifer rubin you're
fired stelter you're fired i'm not doing
a good trump impression but you get it
you're fired what does he do you're
fired like this
anything's possible people i think
there's something happening and if you
see it
you can start linking together some of
the pieces of the future so elon musk
i'm with you the people are with you all
right let's get to the reuben report
locals community q a
christy says love the new book i just
finished listening to it have you guys
reached out to elon musk for an
interview the babylon bee was lucky
enough to get one so hopefully you will
too okay so i've never actually directly
reached out to elon
i think he's probably seen a couple of
my tweets because when i've tweeted at
him or asked him questions uh you know
often things have gotten like 20 000
retweets or crazy numbers he actually
just a few days ago did respond to
something that i tweeted relative to
what's going on with twitter and what i
think the best course of action would be
and all that
so i suspect the guy kinda
knows me whatever it doesn't matter um i
would love to sit down with him i'm not
gonna try right now it's like there's
enough going on he's probably not gonna
be looking to do a lot of interviews
right now
but putting aside the twitter thing
just everything that this guy has done
we don't have that many people that are
brave we don't have that many people
that are true innovators that see the
world in a different way that can create
i mean the guy is a creator more than
anything else the tesla if you have not
been in the tesla is an awesome freaking
car michael you got a tesla in the last
month or so how would you say the tesla
is amazing spaceship amazing spaceship
it's cool man and they use i don't know
if they have it anymore they don't have
the crazy button anymore the ludicrous
button it's gone so they used to have
something on the tesla called the
ludicrous button that's literally what
it was called and if you press the
button the car would explode like a
spaceship i mean it was super dangerous
that must be why they got rid of it but
it's just awesome the tesla has a whole
thing where you can set up whoopee
cushions in other people's seats so you
can just be driving and pressing them
and then different kinds of the extended
fart the short fart everything in
between i mean people need this you know
what i'm saying uh so yes i would like
to talk to elon musk michelle says why
does bill maher think all republicans
are racist what does he think
uh what does he think we are a threat to
democracy i know he's being red-pilled
but he really has some archaic thoughts
about us yeah i mean you guys know my
thoughts on this he's at the end
he's at the end of liberalism and he has
to make the choice and then every time
he gets close he then does something
that's just so crazy you're like man you
you were right there and then you threw
yourself right back into the stupidity
so just last week on his show after
getting so close for so long
he went on this rant about how
republicans would be thrilled if there
were no black supreme court justices and
it's like that is such nonsense i assure
you if there were 12
all clarence thomas clone supreme court
justices like republicans would be
thrilled obviously the idea that they
still boil it all down to race or as he
said that there should be a black seat
on the supreme court like that's just
craziness and he just has to get over
that hump but i suppose i i suppose this
is
something in life it's like we all head
in a certain direction you can sort of
see the promised land in the distance
but that last moment
whether you're gonna go or whether
you're gonna turn back and do all the
things that you knew before that that's
the moment of truth and i i think he's
probably to some degree struggling with
that i think the other thing related to
him that's not fully about race but
connected to race is that he's so deep
on the religious thing and the
anti-religious thing that he's pushed
for so long i mean i saw his documentary
uh religious like the guy hates religion
he does not like believers it's just
it's just how he is he's mocked religion
his whole life you can think of that
what you will
but the fact that the people that now
are defending all the things that he
purports to believe are the religious i
have no doubt he's having some internal
debate there and and
monologue with himself like how could
this be how did this happen
maybe there's a religious story perhaps
is there a parable can someone give me a
religious story that might be worthy of
sending to bill maher that could bring
this thing home is there a biblical
story about the non-believer who
ultimately was defended by the believers
and that's what gave him his redemption
there's got there's got to be something
there give me something
coco says we have vip tickets in denver
and we're so excited reading the book
now what time do we show up at the
gothic theater if we have vip tickets
for the meet and greet the meet and
greet is after the show so show up
normal time for the show and then after
the show we grab all the vip people and
i'll give a separate little talk for the
vip people the shake hand and or the one
second hug the signing of the book the
picture and then who else knows what's
going to happen i don't know maybe we'll
do shots together we'll we'll see what
happens but i'm looking forward to
denver that's the last show of this leg
that we're announcing right now that's
with brian callan it's going to be a fun
one so i hope that you guys can get out
there remember no mask mandates no
vaccine mandates i don't want to see
your papers i don't care what your
medical conditions are come on out if
you want to have a good time dave
rubin.com slash events uh nathan says
hey dave excited to see you and meet you
on your tour in atlanta the home of
chick-fil-a where this gay man happens
to work hot damn
crazy sounding i know i'm curious to
know what is your favorite menu item
from there are you going to bring me
some chick-fil-a in atlanta the home of
chick-fil-a that would be something and
a gay man working at chick-fil-a you
mean they haven't thrown you in the
fryer they're not coming for you they i
can't believe it um
what is my favorite item i always go for
the spicy chicken sandwich i always go
for this but i like the pickles i like
the spicy i like the the fried chicken i
like the whole thing but my team does
know if we have chick-fil-a
we pretty much have to shut it down for
the afternoon it knocks me out it it
takes me out there have been times where
we've had chick-fil-a and you know i've
got something to do big meeting we have
a lot of meetings around here where we
talk about things very seriously and
then suddenly people will be like
where's dave and i'm like upstairs on
the couch just unconscious it's uh it's
it's a it is what it is but i enjoy the
chick-fil-a i like the michael you like
all the sauces name a couple sauces
you got the chick-fil-a sauce the what
polynesian
the what
zesty buffalo it's not just buffalo you
got the barbecue you got your honey
mustard i'm sure barbecue barbecue
ketchup
those are the big ones very good very
good uh i'm really taxing you today um
emily says are you and dave taking time
off once the first baby is born i think
it's so important to have that time to
bond but i really just want to know how
long we will be without the reuben
report so the first baby is due in
august so you know we're off the grid
during august so hopefully we'll have a
couple weeks there
i know what the exact due date is but
it's obviously babies aren't necessarily
born on on the due date uh but we will
have some time as a family and we're
gonna have family here and his mom and
my mom and his sister and my sister will
be around she's pregnant too at the
exact same time supposed to give birth
the day before and we of course we want
all of that time david's going to take
some extended
time off and and really focus on that
i'm going to try to do the show the
second week back in september um it'll
change my schedule obviously a little
bit and from what i understand my my
ability to sleep is going to be greatly
altered so i'm trying to bank a little
sleep right now
but i don't want to take time off now
the the second baby who is due in
october will be a little more difficult
relative to schedule and maybe i'll have
to take a few days off for a week off
it's obviously very amorphous depending
on just a gajillion things so we shall
see but for the august situation uh god
willing i will be back in here
right on september 1st or whatever that
first monday is
after
labor day amanda says what are your
thoughts on the biden administration
continuing this grace period for student
loan repayment we should have done more
on this and maybe next week or we're
touring next week but when i'm back in
studio we'll do a little more on this i
mean look the student loan repayment
thing is basically a bribe that's all
that it is
to say to people you got into debt
by your own choice
and now you're upset that you got into
that debt and we're going to take care
of you even though we know we don't have
any money and we're spending money we
don't have and we're in you know
deflating the value of money because we
keep printing it so we'll just print
more to make it go away
none of it makes any sense but it's a
purely a bribe that if you listen to the
messaging coming out of the biden
administration they're basically saying
it i mean aoc is basically saying to
biden right now this is almost an exact
quote she's like you're not doing well
with young voters you got to do the debt
thing because that she feels that oh if
you in essence give them money give them
that free pass
they'll vote for you i don't know that
they're going to vote for biden either
way but but the thing is it's one of
those issues that if you think about for
more than a second you realize how
faulty it is first off to pay for
someone else is debt i have i have a
mortgage you're going to pay for my
mortgage i mean i have car payments
you're going to pay for that like no one
is deserving of having just a mortgage
or or a loan or whatever it might be
just taken care of like that it could be
done by the grace of god if your friends
or family want to take care of whatever
but not by the government because that's
just somebody else's money that they're
just moving over to you but also the
idea that you get rid of all student
debt you know that there are kids who
come from upper middle class if not rich
families that go to say syracuse
university how much is syracuse
university a year i'm going to guess
it's about 70 grand about 70 let's say
it's about 70 grand 70 grand times four
well times two it's 140 grand times two
again that's 280 grand
these are kids that have money come from
means and everything else now you walk
out into the real world you got your
degree in lesbian archery and you can't
really do anything and you're 280 in
grand why would the government pay for
that back
it just makes no sense it's about 70 or
we are we accepting that i'll take that
as the number you guys can google it
yourself
but it doesn't really make any sense
it's not just and also you're punishing
the people that took care of their debt
that's what you're doing i remember
about five years ago when we finally
paid off david's last college loans he
went to penn state worked real hard got
great grades got a good job life's
worked out and finally we had a little
bit of money when we started making
money about five years ago we paid off
that last thing and it was such joy such
joy that we did it with why did we do it
are we schmucks are we are we pushovers
like what are you going to pay us back
so i guess not only should we pay off
everyone's debt but everyone who's paid
off their debt will pay that off too you
know because we want to be fair we like
equity here in the united states of
america
zionist says are you and david attending
a passover seder on friday night or
saturday night yes we are doing two
seders lots of matzah uh we're going to
jersey to my aunt and uncle and my folks
will be there and cousins and bunch of
other people uh as we as we try to do
every year we got mucked up one year
during lockdowns but there will be
horseradish there will be gefilte fish
we will tell the story of the hebrews
exodus from egypt to the promised land
that place where the progressives of
today don't want jews to live but that
is the story and i love passover
actually because the story of passover
is the story of freedom it is the story
of a people taking responsibility for
their lives and figuring out that you
don't have to be ruled by a king and you
can fight the power and you can survive
and thrive in your own land by your own
belief system and uh and i love the
family as part of it and doing the seder
and that whole thing if you're
putting aside whether you're jewish or
not if you've never been to a passover
seder i would highly recommend it you
know the passover seder is also what
they think jesus's last supper was at a
passover seder in essence um and i would
recommend that everyone i think we got
an image for you
dennis prager has the rational passover
haggadah which it's the number one
selling haggadah if i'm not mistaken and
i just bought about six of these i think
we bought six or eight of them that i'm
going to give to my family and i think
we're going to try to use that as the
haggadah this year dennis does just an
incredible job of explaining
big biblical stories while still
maintaining some of the rational beliefs
that we have and explaining the
difference between metaphor
and story and all of these things and so
we will be checking that out and you can
get it on amazon if you'd like to emma
says what can be done about wokeness in
corporations the parallel economy has
taken a while well look
the twitter thing is is a big boost in
the parallel economy what's going on
with locals and rumbles big boost but do
we need it to speed up yeah do we need
more companies yeah but what can you do
you can cancel a lot of the stuff that
you don't like or that you're paying for
that is working against you whether
that's disney plus or netflix or
whatever it might be uh you can do that
that's a way of doing something you can
try to buy books not just on amazon i
mean i pushed the amazon link but
usually i was pushing uh oh actually 99
of the time i think i was pushing
daverubin.com
book because there we had all the links
so you could go to mom and pop shops i
always encourage people to buy local
when possible we try to do that
ourselves as much as possible it's not
to say we don't use amazon obviously we
do
but you can do a little more to make
sure that the little guy can survive
amongst this woke insanity
wits says stephen crowder said they
would crowd fund to keep brian stelter
on cnn would you be inclined to join
with them yes if that is a real thing
and if it gets to the day that stelter
is going down 500 bucks you got it
crowder reuben will throw in 500
to keep potato
on the air
i enjoy a baked potato by the way you
give me a loaded baked potato
i am pretty much as happy as i can get
sidebar
eagle says what's the most daring thing
on your bucket list and what are your
plans to do it well i would love to do
this uh you know you can orbit the earth
thing but i think didn't uh who did it
william shatner did it i think a few
people have done it now i guess it has a
little something to do with elon musk
and spacex but you can orbit the earth i
used to have a lot of anxiety related to
flying actually and then when i started
touring with jordan i knew i was i was
like i'm going to be in
i don't know i'm going to take 200
flights in a year or something like that
i just have to get over it and i
remember the first day of the
tour we were getting on the plane and i
said dave it's time to get over this
[ __ ] and i just killed the fear i
have no fear of flying anymore it's
really weird i was just able to say to
myself isn't enough is enough and i
don't have that problem anymore so i
yeah something in space send me out to
space maybe that's all where this is all
heading anyway you know enough of this
i've done everything i can do on earth
i've tried you know the one thing they
can't say but they can't say he didn't
give it the old college try to save
earth i tried so let's you know i'd like
to go up to elysium live up there with
those people with the food and the wine
and that whole thing
phil oh speaking of elysium just on a
sidebar if you haven't seen the movie
elysium it's um who's the guy that did
it the director what's his name
neil
he also did uh district nine and just a
few days ago on sunday we had nothing to
do we watched chappie
these are great sci-fi movies that have
really powerful did you see chappie
freaking awesome movie that have
powerful messages related to humanity
and our struggles and class warfare and
all bunch of stuff so it's uh elysium
well district 9 was the first one
elysium and chappie was the last one
phil says as we know inflation is
absolutely killing us right now and it
appears to me that the dollar may
collapse where would you put any savings
or excess money i mean look the bitcoin
thing
it's real the crypto thing and the
decentralized thing it's all real the
idea that you can exchange
money and you can exchange goods and
services without the middleman of the
government and within without the system
that at any point because of a bad
decision by a man with dementia can
devalue the currency that is very very
cool and what's nice here in miami i
mean this is the hub of it now it was
san francisco it's all moved here
i went to a talk last week where mayor
suarez
here in miami was talking and you know
he's the one that really he sent out
that tweet you may remember this and i
did an interview with him where we talk
about it uh a guy by the name of keith
roboy who works at peter thiel's
founder's fund one of the biggest vc
funds over in san francisco it was there
now they're here
he had said something about uh i've been
thinking about moving to miami this is
like two years ago in the middle of
lockdown and mayor suarez sent a tweet
to him and said how can i help
that tweet blew up keith ruboy then
moved here to miami and actually the
event that i was at was at keith's house
i mentioned all of this because it then
started a tech revolution here which is
happening in miami which is why so many
people are coming here and they're
voting the right way and there's such a
beautiful thing happening so i was at
this event and suarez was it was during
bitcoin week last week and suarez
or the bitcoin conference last week and
suarez is just he's so forward thinking
on all this stuff he he's a good guy
he's trying to get all these companies
here it's why we moved locals here
locals is building awesome offices and
studios right now as we speak and uh and
yeah so i think getting
at least even though i know a lot of it
feels futurey and weird and it's like
what's it based on and all that stuff
like get a little bit of bitcoin get a
little bit of ethereum get involved in
that a little bit and see what happens
chris says dave i believe you said that
when you lived in california you were a
registered democrat now as a floridian
how are you registered republican
democrat or unaffiliated thanks 100
honestly i have been so freaking busy
that i have not been able to get a
driver's license yet we have the
appointment with the dmv
i think it's in like two weeks when i
have a little break on the tour but i
assure you
with 100 certitude i will be registering
as a republican here in the free state
of florida as i often say
you don't have to be a republican but
you cannot be a democrat i will be a
republican it does not mean i will agree
with everything on the republican party
platform or everyone that is a
republican okay fine we get it
but uh i want the republican party to
remain strong here i think we have a
really great republican party here
obviously led by desantis but i know so
many of the people now
and i want to strengthen that it does
not matter if i agree with every little
thing i don't even know that i have
great differences on any level at this
point with them
but they are here to defend freedom and
defend defend the sovereignty of this
state and allow you to live freely so
yes i will be registering as a
republican
dave says to dave uh can you tell the
story of you and david buying your first
gun that's a lot of david's as someone
who grew up with guns i'm fascinated
when disaffected liberals turned
pro-second amendment and buy guns
themselves or maybe you were always pro
second amendment i'd love to hear your
story no i really shifted on guns i mean
that's when i really shifted on i was
never against the second amendment i've
always believed that you have the right
to defend yourself and to defend your
family and all that but i really really
shifted in the chaos of the lockdowns uh
we were at our house
not the last house i lived in we lived
in a different house where the garage
was where the reuben report was shot out
of when we were doing a lot of in-studio
stuff
and we lived off a main road in los
angeles and when the riots the blm and
antifa riots were coming the riots kept
going basically by our house so it's not
that the mass crowd was going right in
front of our house but a lot of people
walking into the mass crowd were going
there and uh we did not feel safe we did
not feel safe i was obviously worried
that people knew where i lived which
it's impossible almost to hide where you
live especially in a place like los
angeles for a series of reasons because
of celebrity and just snoops and all of
that kind of stuff
and it did not feel safe there was
suddenly out of nowhere there was
suddenly a lot of crime in our
neighborhood houses were being broken
into
and there were just vagrants around the
homeless thing kept increasing
all of that but with the riots kept when
the riots kept going by
we just started feeling like if
something happened like can we call the
police and would they even show up
because that was also in the midst of
defund the police so we started
realizing how much more important it was
to have
uh the ability to defend ourselves and
then i'll tell you one day well actually
before we got the gun
our previous dog you guys probably
remember emma had just passed away in
february of 2020 right before lockdowns
she was 16 she lived a great life
and we didn't want to get a dog for a
while plus my book my first book was
coming out we wanted a little break i
was going to be on a book tour but then
when all hell was breaking loose you
know there's some statistic it's
something like if you have a dog even if
you have just like a little yipping
pomeranian your house is uh like 90
percent less likely to be broken into
because if a robber is casing a house
he's looking at two houses they look
exactly the same but he knows one has a
dog one doesn't it's just an extra
factor so they usually don't so that was
another reason that we grabbed clyde it
was really because
the lockdowns were starting and they
were going to kill all these dogs and i
literally just ran to the shelter and
grabbed him i tell the story in the book
but it was also it would be good to have
a dog around but we realized that wasn't
enough too we wanted a gun so we uh
how'd we do it we i have a friend who
need not be mentioned but it's a public
person who uh a former lefty him or
herself
uh who
had a friend who was a gun dealer and it
was by the way it was very hard it's
always hard to get guns in california
but then it was crazy hard because
everybody wanted guns suddenly so we
went to the gun shop it was about uh 45
minutes away or so and it was jam-packed
but we had somebody that gave us really
great service you know it took some time
because you have to fill out the
paperwork then there's the waiting list
and the background checks and all that
stuff we had to get familiar with the
guns
long process but yes we have guns and i
believe you should be able to defend
yourself and your family without
question and i would say i'm as
pro-second amendment as you possibly
could be
missy says what do you think of
answering the left's anger over the
florida bill with okay groomer fair or
not okay i'm glad you asked this one
because i've been asked this on a couple
other shows i have not addressed it on
this show so first off i have not used
the ok groomer phrase once on this show
i have tried very hard to calmly explain
to you what bill hb1557 is i have tried
to explain to you that it has nothing to
do with being gay you could just as
easily call it don't say straight
etcetera etcetera what uh what amy's
talking about sorry was it amy what was
her name on that one what missy is
talking about there uh is that a lot of
people online are just now saying okay
they're just responding okay groomer to
anyone that's for the
hb1557 and the implication is somehow
that all democrats are pedophiles or
something like that i chose not to get
involved in that um but i get the
inclination to fight fire with fire i
really do also i don't know what a
better i had i went on guy benson's
radio show a couple days ago and he
asked me about this it's actually the
first time i've addressed it publicly
and he asked me if i thought it was a
good phrase to use or not and i said to
him although i have not used it if you
want to talk to someone else's child
that's six years old about sex or gender
or sexuality and you want to do that
privately and alone and you don't want
to inform the parent of that
conversation what would be a better word
now i think his response was
indoctrinator
um i don't i'm not attacking a guy when
i say this like i don't know is
indoctrinator less offensive than
groomer and is that more effective in
getting the point across i don't know um
but in essence i don't think groomer
itself necessarily means pedophile like
you're
you're just trying to confuse a child
for a million different reasons why
would you want to confuse a child it's
just because you want to confuse them
about sex or is it what you want to
confuse them about the nature of the
world and who they can be uh who should
be responsible for them and who they
should trust in all of those things and
then once you've broken that in an
innocent six-year-old what else could
you get them to believe like i think
that
means has more to do with it than than
so specifically just the sex thing um so
if you want to say it to those people
it's fine i i think their intentions are
really horrible i really do there's just
no need for any of this they lie about
everything so okay if you want to fight
back in a way that you might not be 100
cool with all the time like you got to
do what you got to do
amy says with the book tour starting
next week inquiring minds need to know
how do you prepare for a show and do you
have a ritual um
you know
not really i kind of i get to the well
they've i'll tell you this you get a
little rider when you when you sign a
contract for a tour where they say well
what do you want at each menu i ask for
unsweetened iced coffee and a couple
bottles of water that's it i don't want
food i don't want booze i don't want
anything else i try to have a very the
shows are mostly at eight o'clock so
i'll probably have a very light meal at
about five o'clock uh no drinking or
anything like that uh get there i do
like a little bit of the caffeine right
before i go on stage and
you know i usually try and this is what
i was doing with jordan or whenever i've
done stand-up or when i speak at college
events or whatever for about two minutes
before i try to just get my thoughts in
order you know i'll think about all
right what have i been thinking about
all day long and i kind of do it like
that i kind of closed my eyes right like
what have i been thinking about what's
been sort of rattling in the back of my
head not just all the stuff that i'm
doing all day but what else is there and
what do i how do i want to organize that
and then i try to sort of roughly write
something in my head where i'm like okay
so i know i want to say this first i
want to get a big laugh when i walk out
on stage
usually something different every night
then i want to link it to this i want to
make you know this comment about biden
and then let's go from there but i i
really don't have an end point
necessarily you know it's funny when
when jordan and i'm sure many of you
came to the jordan shows i would always
make fun of him not uh
not
in the nicest possible way at the end of
the show because jordan would give this
unbelievable
hour-long talk different every night i'd
watch him stretch the limits of his
intellect and the whole thing but
because he didn't prepare them in such a
way that they were they were fully
scripted he would often end by saying
something like and you know
and that's all i've got to say about
that good night
and i always thought it was a funny way
of ending it because it was sort of like
forest gump remember the ending of far
is going and that's all i've got to say
about that like you say this amazing
story you tell these incredible thoughts
and all of this stuff you link all of
this incredible stuff together and then
the ending feels almost anticlimactic
there was something sort of nice about
it so i will try to end with a big laugh
but some nights it will be it's just
going to be different every night that
that really is it so i guess my ritual
is not over preparing uh in closing
ladies gentlemen
and other assorted people i'm not a
biologist i'm going on tour on tuesday
if you have not bought tickets buy the
freaking tickets now would ya
davereuben.com
events we kick it off in west palm beach
on tuesday night and then we're in
clearwater which is the tampa area here
in florida and then we're bouncing
around north carolina georgia chicago
we're going to dallas oh we're going to
new york we're going to cali all the
usual stops you will have fun i promise
you i think there's some vip tickets
left and if there aren't we'll figure
out a way to make it work once you're
there just just get uh get on board i
promise you're gonna have a good time uh
if you wanna play along during the live
chat during the shows
reubenport.locals.com
part three of my interview of michael
knowles interviewing me is up right now
on youtube and rumble and the full
things up already on
locals and my interview with david janet
the uh better half around here the other
david uh is up on locals at
reubenport.locals.com
that's all i have to say about that have
a great weekend and hopefully i'll see a
whole bunch of you next week bye
thank you guys for tuning in to the
reuben report direct message we're live
on rumble blaze tv and youtube every
weekday at 11 a.m eastern 8 a.m pacific
don't forget to review share and
subscribe to this podcast and if you're
looking for early and exclusive content
you can join me on locals at
reubenreport.locals.com